good morning it's tuesday so i have a
new book coming out which would be a
great title for this video if i hadn't
made an absurd and increasingly
ridiculous commitment several months ago
but
one must get the show on so here we are
for the last two and a half years i've
been writing a podcast called the
anthropocene reviewed which is a little
hard to describe like the premise is
that i review different facets of the
human-centered planet on a five-star
scale like i might review the bacterium
staphylococcus aureus or the concept of
love at first sight or the
taco bell breakfast menu but that's not
actually what the podcast is about it's
about like
hope and whether it is justified and
it's about how people can be so
wonderful but also
so horrible and how humans are at once
forces of astonishing creation
and gut-wrenching destruction and it's
about the contemporary human paradox of
being at once far
too powerful and not nearly powerful
enough
like powerful enough to reshape the
entire climate of the planet but not
powerful enough to reshape it in a way
that's
beneficial i don't know though that
makes it sound very serious and i want
the essays to be funny and also
sometimes sad i'm very bad at talking
about my own work
i guess the reviews are my attempt to
pay attention to what i pay attention to
to borrow a line from my friend amy
cross rosenthal
and over the last year i've been
expanding and revising some of the
reviews from the podcast and also
writing some new ones and now
the anthropocene reviewed is going to be
a book it's my first book of nonfiction
and i am very nervous
and or excited one symptom of 2020 for
me is that i genuinely can't tell if
it's an
and or an ore but anyway the
anthropocene reviewed book will be
published on may 18
2021 and it is available for pre-order
now also there will be an audio book
read by me the response to the podcast
in general and especially to the
most recent quite personal episode has
been really
overwhelming in the best possible way
i've never been
as worried about sharing something as i
was about that episode and people have
been
so generous so thank you i hope you like
the book
but wait you ask will you be signing the
entire first printing of the book like
you did with the fault in our stars
as it happens yes i will be signing the
entire first printing of the american
and canadian edition which unfortunately
means that if you live
outside the us or canada even if you
order an american english language
edition it will probably
not be signed i'm really sorry about
that but the systems of international
printing and shipping just
don't allow for that but if you live in
the u.s or canada and you pre-order the
book it will be signed i would like to
say that i'm doing this as a gift for
people who pre-order the book or
whatever
but no i'm doing it for myself i would
like to make a small repeated mark on a
piece of paper over a hundred thousand
times in a way that hopefully makes at
least some people happy and
this opportunity has conveniently
emerged somewhat related look at my
circles
i have so far drawn 17 000 circles in my
attempt to understand the number 170
000. this is so many circles that it
might freak out the youtube compression
algorithm
and yet it is only 10 of the circles i
need to draw now astute observers will
note that i have somewhat less than 90
of the paper remaining to draw 90 of the
circles how will this problem resolve
itself
i look forward to finding out also
related it has been really lovely to see
the circles that many of you are drawing
some because you're trying to grieve a
loss some because you are trying to
understand your own large numbers and
some because you like me also find
relief in doodling i'm really grateful
to all of you who've shared circles on
the nerdfighter subreddit or nerdfighter
discords and so on hank as i discuss on
the most recent episode of the
anthropocene reviewed it has been a long
and at times very challenging
three years since my last book turtles
all the way down was published but
writing these essays has also been
the most fun i've had writing since
maybe
ever in fact i'm going to go get back to
it i'll see you on fr
way i should say that the anthropocene
reviewed book comes out on may 18th
2021 and is available for pre-order now
and then i say
i'll see you on friday i'll see you on
friday you're a good brother
i never would have done this if it
hadn't been for you so thank you for
encouraging me to do it thank you
goodbye